Greg I want to uh put put a a
hypothetical scenario on the table and
get your perspective on this so let's
say I'm working with a dietitian who is
qualified to give me a full meal plan
and this dietitian that I'm working with
we have very ambitious goals we want to
try to kind of thread the needle and
Peak for two very different sports at
the same time maybe a professional
bodybuilding show and even something way
different like a professional classic
bodybuilding show okay so we're it's a
it's an ambitious protocol we're putting
together and they're helping me with my
fat loss as I prepare for these
competitions
and so they say Eric you're supposed to
have uh chicken and sweet potato for
this meal
and I say well I'm sick of this food I
can't I can't bear to eat more chicken
and sweet potato instead I want to have
some turkey and a white potato now I'm
gonna arrange them so that the the carbs
fat protein fiber hypothetically I'm
gonna make it all work
am I making an upgrade a downgrade or am
I going to be making the same exact
amount of progress moving forward
uh I think you'll probably make ooh well
it depends on the extent to which you
subscribe to the John Harbaugh School of
nutrition that's interesting um I think
the published research would tend to
suggest that you would probably make
about the same progress with both of
those approaches but
as we know chicken is a nervous bird and
maybe if you're trying to win you don't
want a bunch of chicken in your diet I
don't know where turkey fits on the
nervous bird hierarchy uh but for to
answer that question we we might need to
call in an expert they do
they do run if you get too close to them
in the forest like wild turkeys so they
might be nervous birds as well if if
they are conditional on that I would say
probably similar progress with both
approaches now my understanding is that
Benjamin Franklin wanted the turkey to
be the national bird of the United
States so that tells me that they've got
you know they're a little bit more
resilient a little bit tougher than a
chicken I would assume just in terms of
their uh you know their their
temperament and their composition yeah
but Ben Franklin also wasn't your
classic tough guy that's true but anyway
so
uh do you know the the uh the acronym i
i f y m stands for If It Fits your
Macros do you know where that came from
originally I thought it came from the
bodybuilding.com uh misc board but I
don't know if that's true so my
understanding I don't know the exact
area where it popped up I believe that's
correct but you know whatever I'm not
going to commit to it without doing the
research on it but the the general Vibe
the reason that this whole acronym came
to be is because people were on these
you know bodybuilding message boards
saying well I want to swap out this food
for that food I want to swap out that
food for the other food can I do this
and still succeed with my weight loss
goal or hypertrophy goal or whatever the
case is and people would say dude If It
Fits your Macros just do it it's fine if
you're equating your carb fat and
protein intake and in some cases your
fiber intake for the day as well uh
usually fiber they talk about across the
whole day not within an individual food
swap but if it fits the macro plan the
the carb fat and protein Target that
you're shooting for every day just do it
it's fine you're going to end up in the
same place and that uh you know that
whole idea of If It Fits your Macros the
more kind of formal term for that that
has gained popularity is flexible
dieting
and flexible dieting that the flexible
part pertains to flexibility with
regards to Food Source selection
basically the idea is flexible dieting
means you can choose whatever food
sources you prefer to hit your macro
Targets on a daily basis and make
totally satisfactory progress toward
your body composition goals and
flexible dieting or If It Fits your
Macros it is a valid concept it works
broadly speaking you know you are not
restricted to the like seven classic
bodybuilder Foods right so back in the
day when people started cutting they
would say oh I have to eat this very
rigid restrictive short list of foods
that bodybuilders just traditionally eat
it was a lot of white fish like tilapia
or tilapia I don't know how to say it
chicken breast rice sweet potato
broccoli the whole deal uh there's a
classic video back in the day where
someone was prepping for a bodybuilding
show and like literally all he ate was
uh I think it was uh fish and rice cakes
do you ever see that video yeah
um but yeah so people are restricting
themselves to these very tiny food lists
and it was unnecessary right
so people with and this was a very
positive thing a net a net benefit here
for the bodybuilding world and the
fitness world uh collectively this idea
of flexible dieting If It Fits your
Macros this is valid and it works and
and it indicates that we have a lot of
flexibility for what food choices we
make what food sources we select to hit
our daily macro targets
however there has been a downside of you
know this uh this trend in which people
have broadly embraced that concept and I
want to demonstrate the downside by by
sharing two different statements so the
first statement is as follows
you have flexibility to select from a
wide range of food sources in accordance
with your goals and preferences there
are no foods that are fully off limits
for Fitness enthusiasts
that's a true statement that's good the
second statement food source selection
doesn't matter
a lot of people have transitioned from
the first sentence to the second the
first statement to the second
almost kind of implying equivalence and
the purpose of my my segment here is to
highlight the fact that those are two
very different statements and what I'm
trying to get at here is
when it comes to food source selection
you can pick from an almost Limitless
range of food sources that part of
flexible dieting I absolutely support
it's simply true
but I think a lot of times people try to
take that a step further and act like
food source selection is completely uh
meaningless like it has no impact on
your dietary progress and success and I
don't think that that is true because my
belief based on the research
is that food source selection is a
variable that we can strategically
leverage we can make food swaps uh
strategically to set ourselves up for a
diet that is basically going to set us
up for more success as we move forward
so before I get into that I want to give
a little bit of background information
about the regulation of food intake and
I'm just completely pulling this from a
really incredible guest article that we
had in the mass research review by Dr
Ann Catherine isolt and it was all about
the kind of
neurophysiological elements of food
intake regulation
so food intake as she explained in this
article is regulated by several
interrelated brain circuits and as I
talk through this I'm going to show some
images on the screen that kind of show
what these these circuits look like so
the first one is the hunger circuit uh
and there are of course a number of gut
derived hormones and hormones derived
from adipose tissue are produced by
adipose tissue that work their way up uh
into the hypothalamus and relay signals
about the regulation of hunger there's
also the satiety circuit uh and what we
see is that the satiety circuit involves
a number of different brain structures
that are they're all in the the
hypothalamus and hindbrain regions but
it's certainly a complicated circuit
with a lot of different brain structures
that are involved in this communication
and this regulation and there are a
number of peripheral structures that are
highly involved in that satiety circuit
as well also can I just say brain
circuits sound like stuff out of sci-fi
yes like arcuate nucleus ventral
tegmental area
dorsal striatum like that that all that
all sounds like places in like a Sci-Fi
City or something absolutely yeah the
brain stuff gets serious but the third
uh brain circuit that I want to talk
about here is the consumption circuit
this is another one where the
hypothalamus is heavily involved and it
includes reward responses to hyper
palatable food okay so uh we've got
hunger satiety and then this consumption
circuit uh which involves the reward
centers in our brain and specifically
how they relate to the consumption of
food that's hyper palatable or just
really really really tasty and gives us
this uh this really nice sensation of
reward when we consume them so another
brain structure that's involved here
which is a little bit simpler is the
prefrontal cortex and uh the prefrontal
cortex is heavily involved with Goal
directed behavior and impulse control so
the prefrontal cortex the hypothalamus
the hind brain we've got all these
different brain structures and areas
that are working together conveying
different signals but you know they're
they're integrating all of this
peripheral information so that we can
kind of control our food intake and
there's this kind of give and take
between these different systems right
now the reason that I bring that up uh
this kind of integrated control of
feeding is because uh it it's pretty
important when we talk about uh swapping
out food sources right so let's say that
you are weighing one carb Source versus
another or one protein Source versus
another a lot of people like to reduce
that and basically say well you know
carbs or carbs protein is protein right
so when we talk about food sources and
how they impact hunger and satiety one
of the most common questions people ask
is uh you know are carbs more satiating
than fats or is protein more satiating
than carbs a lot of people like to break
it down simply into macros and there's
some utility of that but I think that's
the wrong question to ask when it comes
to how is this food going to actually
influence my feeding behaviors my actual
food intake because there are all these
different brain structures that are kind
of conveying all these different
messages and and communicating with one
another to collectively modulate energy
intake so a lot of times with satiety or
regulation of intake people want to make
it just a question about macro content
and I think that's the wrong question to
be asking it's not irrelevant but it's
way too superficial to really get to the
the root of what you're trying to figure
out here when you're weighing one food
source versus another so things you want
to ask yourself are these two different
food sources that I'm comparing do they
impact my brain's reward system to the
same extent and things that are going to
play into that would be the aroma the
flavor the mouth feel of the food the
ease of consumption other contextual
factors that will influence your
experience your subjective experience of
consuming that food are they going to
impact satiety to the same extent of
course macronutrient breakdown plays a
role but normally with food swaps we're
talking about meals that we kind of
assume the macro content is going to be
relatively equated in this context but
we want to look at things like what is
the mass of this meal what is the volume
of the meal the texture the rate of
consumption the fiber content the water
content the energy density which of
course is kind of tied in with several
of those elements and then also when
we're when we're comparing two different
food sources we might ask ourselves do
these food sources actually play the
same role within the meal and interact
with other Foods the same way you know
there are some foods that kind of make
us want to consume more of a different
food because they go really well
together and there are other foods that
we could put it in a meal and it would
not have that same effect you know
there's almost a bit of synergy where
certain food pairings we say those two
together those make it really hard to
put the spoon down right so there's a
lot that goes into potential food swaps
I think a good example of that because I
I think that may come across as like
abstract to some folks yeah but I think
a good example of that is if someone is
really into eating chicken wings yeah
like the carrots and celery that come
with the chicken wings are just kind of
like to give your your mouth a break
just from the The Heat Of The Wings to
kind of cool cool off so you can go in
with more wings so it's like
theoretically like you know if you get
an order of 20 wings and that's all you
could eat maybe you might want to only
eat 10 or maybe a dozen of them before
you're just like oh this is just it's
salty vinegary spicy like I'm kind of
done with this you know but then if you
can kind of cool off with a little
celery maybe dipped in some blue cheese
dressing you're like ooh this is nice
little flavor contrast texture contrast
cool the mouth down you know it would be
good some more fatty spicy vinegary
salty chicken wings yeah so yeah yeah
and one that comes to mind for me
um
is a really simple one but uh the idea
of having coffee versus green tea so in
a vacuum I enjoy both of them very much
but when I drink coffee sometimes I say
you know what would go great with this
something chocolatey or maybe a pastry
or something sweet or kind of like a
creamy like dessert type of thing uh
when I drink green tea this could
totally be uh just my perspective
I don't think a lot of foods go
particularly well with green tea or at
least not a lot of foods that I consume
regularly so if I drink green tea I can
say this is a lovely cup of tea and I
don't want anything else yeah this is
great but when I drink coffee I do start
to want something that's sweet or
chocolatey or something like that and so
it's one thing where a little beverage
swap can really make a big difference
about what other Foods you might
gravitate toward you know or if I was
eating something that goes well with
coffee if I was going to end my meal
with coffee
maybe I'm more likely to actually
continue that meal and eat even more
yeah you know versus if I had some tea
after that meal and it was just a clear
signal okay meals over we're on to a
completely different set of flavors here
right so so that's what I'm getting at
is the fact that when we talk about
making a food swap it's not just about
if the macros equate we have to consider
a broader picture of how all these
different brain structures communicate
with one another and regulate food
intake
um and you know a great example like I
said the the prefrontal cortex is
heavily involved with Goal directed
Behavior one of the things that can be
really helpful with food source
selection is if we don't necessarily
have to work too hard to kind of you
know so if you eat a lot of really hyper
palatable meals that for you are just a
10 out of 10 on the flavor scale yeah
you're like this is incredible every
time the meal ends it's a tragedy you
are really pushing yourself to weigh
this massive reward response versus goal
directed behavior and there's this tug
of war that you are really amplifying by
doing that and so one of the things when
your internal dialogue is Guy Fieri's
external Dialogue on Diners Drive-Ins
and Dives you might you might run into
issues exactly and so again we can
strategically leverage that and say you
know what if I dropped from a meal that
for me is just a 10 out of 10 in terms
of palatability and I went to like a
seven out of ten and it was still a very
nice meal but I can be done with it and
not just feel absolutely distraught that
the meal's over that can be a really
helpful thing when dieting so when I
transitioned to a fat loss phase I do
something that some people view as
counterintuitive but I actually go
toward foods that are slightly less
palatable rather than trying to say okay
I only have 2 100 calories today how do
I make that as palatable as possible
which a lot of people do and for frankly
I kind of think they'd be better off if
they didn't go that route so what I'm
getting at here is
Foods contribute a lot more than their
macros not just in terms of like
micronutrients and stuff like that but
also in how they impact
our bodies systems that regulate food
intake and that means uh you know we
have to look at food sources and
consider more than just you know making
the macros fit there's a lot more that
goes into it when it comes to regulation
of food intake so what I want to do is
look at a couple studies that have said
okay let's actually put this to the test
so let's not just say Okay protein is
more satiating than carbs so if you want
to be satiated eat more protein let's
look at actual Foods
and see how they impact subjective
satiety levels and also how much people
tend to eat after the meal or in
combination with that food right so the
first paper paper I want to look at is a
classic by Holt and colleagues in 1995
if you've ever heard of the satiety
Index this is where it originated what
they did was they gave uh servings of 1
000 kilojoules which is uh 240
kilocalories or Capital C calories uh
they looked at 38 different foods split
into six different food categories so
fruits Bakery products snack foods
carbohydrate-rich Foods protein-rich
foods and breakfast cereals and they fed
these servings to these individuals in
the study and looked at their satiety
ratings over the next
120 Minutes or two hours and what I'm
going to show on the screen is is the
general finding here what they did was
they they made white bread the kind of
standard score of a hundred percent so
all of these were framed as a satiety
index score as a percentage in
comparison to white bread so anything
over a hundred percent was more
satiating than white bread and anything
under a hundred percent was less
satiating than white bread again giving
a 240 calorie uh serving of all these
different foods in isolation and so
generally speaking when you look at the
satiety index it was a really great
piece of research a very valuable thing
that was contributed uh the general
pattern was that foods with uh low
energy density
high fiber content high water content
those were generally foods that in a
vacuum lent themselves to Greater
satiety responses and that's pretty
straightforward and it kind of conforms
with you know what most people consider
to be kind of diet foods when you go on
a diet and you're trying to reduce
calorie intake without starving all day
people do tend to gravitate toward these
types of foods so this was a great piece
of research but there was a shortcoming
in the sense that this paper has low
ecological validity it's not very
representative of real world eating
scenarios because it's not very often
that we say ah I think I'm going to sit
down and have 240 calories of white
bread and nothing else yeah or I'm going
to sit down and have 240 calories of
white potatoes with absolutely nothing
else right so
what's really interesting is you know
looking at research that kind of builds
upon this and says well in the context
of a regular diet in a free living
individual who's eating meals with food
combination combinations that they
selected over the course of a real day
in their normal life what foods seem to
be associated with greater or lesser
energy intake broadly speaking so I want
to talk about a paper by Horgan and
colleagues and that's exactly what they
were looking at so
rather than looking at a controlled
feeding Sim uh scenario with a single
isolated food they said let's look at
all of your food records over a four day
period and they had uh 6 000 four day
diet records that were completed by a
ton of people over in the United Kingdom
and they were looking at you know if we
sort these different foods into 60
distinct categories
How does each of these food categories
influence overall energy intake and I am
going to show some figures that don't
contain 60 categories because that would
be a really big figure so not all
categories are represented Within These
figures but they did sort these into a
total of 60 categories and they looked
at this two different ways which is
really cool and really valuable this was
a very insightful way to look at it they
looked at how these different food
categories influenced energy intake both
within individuals and between
individuals
So within individuals they're basically
looking at how changing your intake of a
particular food influences your kind of
day-to-day fluctuation and energy intake
so on the days you ate more of this food
you ate fewer calories you know and vice
versa uh they also looked at between
individual uh differences so in this
case they were looking at the people who
eat more of this food seem to eat fewer
calories than the people who eat less of
this food right so that's kind of how
you frame these two different uh ways of
looking at the data between individuals
and within individuals so on the screen
right now you're going to see what they
call the compensation coefficient
between individuals and generally
speaking the lower this this value is or
the more negative the more it leads to a
reduction in energy intake I know that's
kind of a weird way to frame it but you
could I don't want to use satiety
incorrectly here because that's not not
strictly what it is but when you have a
low coefficient it basically means the
you know the people who eat more of
these low coefficient Foods tend to eat
less than the people who are eating more
High coefficient Foods that's kind of
the the very basic surface level
interpretation so if you were going to
be for example choosing foods that would
help you reduce your energy intake very
passively you would want to be selecting
foods with a low coefficient right and
so you can kind of look at these and I'm
going to give a broad summary so people
are just like looking through you know
dozens of categories here I'm also going
to display the uh the data here for the
uh the coefficients within individuals
so again just looking at the data a
slightly different way and what you see
is generally speaking there's you look
at the top of these figures with some of
these low coefficient food groups skim
milk a lot of high fiber breakfast
cereals fruit things like that stuff
that's generally uh you know have some
pretty similar characteristics that I'll
get into but one of the things that's
really fascinating when you look through
this is there's a lot of variability a
lot of noise in the data from food to
food it's not like the first three are
all vegetables and then the second three
are all fruits and then the next you
know it's not neatly categorized in the
way you would expect and there are some
some uh some foods that kind of surprise
you a little bit right so uh for example
smoothies end up being a really high
coefficient food whereas most people
would say hey you're putting some you
know some uh fruit maybe some vegetables
a little bit of yogurt in there with
some milk seems healthy enough to me
ends up being a really high coefficient
food uh one of the things that I I
thought was really funny was
man I've seen so much bad internet
content about
like oh man butter is so good for you
it's a superfood you should spread it on
everything
polyunsaturated fatty acids basically
poison stay away from them at all costs
I've seen other people saying no pufas
higher satiety per calorie you know
better from a cardio metabolic
standpoint definitely go with these pufa
based spreads these polyunsaturated fat
based spreads when you look at it in the
context of this it's like man what a
useless argument to go down like in turn
in terms of like when people make
arguments about like oh all you have to
do is swap your margarine for butter and
you're going to reduce your energy
intake or vice versa yeah uh when it
when it comes to impacts on energy
intake they're looking pretty similar
now different cardio metabolic effects
for sure I don't want to make it seem
like they have completely equivalent
effects on blood lipids that's not the
case but that's a discussion for a
different time but uh anyway if we look
at the results in paint with a broad
brush like I said there are some
interesting uh instances where like you
know for example uh specific alcoholic
beverages might find themselves in very
different standings in term terms of the
the actual coefficient there was a lot
of variability and a lot of noise when
you go from food to food and it didn't
fit into these like perfectly tidy bins
that you could categorize easily but a
few notable food categories with low
coefficients were foods that had low
energy density
foods with high fiber content and foods
that were artificially sweetened foods
and beverages I should say that were
artificially sweetened some things with
high coefficients again lending
themselves to higher total energy intake
in the day we're foods that generally
tended to be very snackable but just
based on the context in which they're
normally eaten alcoholic beverages
generally but not in all cases spreads
that you might put on a bread-based
product so like butter margarine Jam
jellies they were all pretty high
coefficient things and that's to be
expected based on the context in which
they're consumed and then full sugar
beverages were definitely a high
coefficient category and we could kind
of lump smoothies into that because a
lot of commercially prepared smoothies
do tend to be quite high in sugar a lot
higher than most people anticipate yeah
um so one thing I want to mention here
is that I'm not saying we should be
using this totally in place base of the
satiety index because you know it's not
a better or worse situation when we look
at these coefficients versus satiety
index values but these are two very
different ways of viewing the problem
right so
uh these coefficients they they have a
lot of ecological validity when we
compare them to the satiety index study
but this is observational data and I
know this is cliche but in this
particular scenario we have to be very
cautious about resisting the urge to
imply or infer causation based on
correlation so there might be a food
that just because of the context in
which it is routinely eaten it lends
itself to being lumped on like a high
energy intake day or mixed with high
energy intake Foods it may not be
because of a specific characteristic of
the food but more reflective of the
context in which it's consumed so the
Practical takeaway here from this study
you know in light of some of those
limitations or caveats the results
largely support the satiety promoting
effects of a dietary pattern that
features a lot of foods with low energy
density plenty of fiber and it also
reins enforces the utility of switching
from sugar beverage Sugar Sugar
sweetened beverages to low calorie
beverages that are you know flavored
with either artificial or non-nutritive
sweeteners so things like uh you know
monk fruit extract Splenda sucralose
those are the same thing aspartame or
your favorite Stevia which I know you're
a big Stevia head
um completely untrue and you'll be
hearing from my lawyers that is slander
per se yes uh they're also uh I think
these findings give us kind of a
cautionary lesson which is you know we
really ought to be mindful of extra
calories that sneak in when for example
we're at an event where we're drinking
alcoholic beverages uh or you know in a
social environment or situation where uh
you know we're very likely to just have
high calorie snack food available being
very very conscious of calorie intake in
those situations can be helpful but I
think the results also mind us to focus
on broader eating patterns whereas the
satiety index kind of convinced people
to look at individual Foods in isolation
and ultimately you know looking at
broader eating patterns and kind of the
uh the entire Matrix of the meal and how
Foods fit together and how eating one
food causes you to eat more of another
food that's a really important aspect
with food source selection that often
gets overlooked other noteworthy studies
on this topic of putting together meals
strategically there's one by Hall and
colleagues the title was Ultra processed
diets cause excess calorie intake and
weight gain and inpatient randomized
controlled trial of AD libidum food
intake as you would guess based on the
title they found in the study that
processed foods are generally consumed
in excess for multiple different reasons
they're often consumed faster they have
a a lower effect on suppressing appetite
acutely and yeah there's a number of
characteristics of these highly Ultra
processed foods that broadly speaking
can lend themselves to higher energy
intakes along those lines there's a
study by Taylor and colleagues called
texture-based differences in eating rate
influence energy intake for minimally
processed and Ultra processed meals and
so basically what they found was they
didn't just look at the level of
processing with with meals but also the
texture of the meals and they found that
when people were given a soft and highly
processed meal they tend to eat eat more
quickly and generally eat more and when
we look at the literature looking at
meals that are harder in texture and
lower in their degree of processing
usually that's going to involve a little
bit more chewing we spend more time with
the the Aromas and the flavors of that
food it gives our satiety signals a
little bit more time to basically kick
in upon the onset of eating and so what
they found in this study is that eating
rate and energy intake were influenced
by not just the degree of processing but
also just the texture of the food again
again with hard textures and low degree
of processing generally promoting a
slower eating rate and less energy
intake there's also a study by Flynn and
colleagues that just came out very
recently where they were looking at what
actually sends the signal to kind of say
okay the meal's over let's shut it down
we're done eating and what's really
interesting is they looked at energy
density and they found that
changing the energy density of the of a
meal was very uh useful from a strategic
perspective but only to a point what
they found was if you can incorporate
some foods with low energy density
and energy density what we're talking
about there is the energy content in
kilocalories divided by the mass of food
in grams uh and like I said usually
foods with a lot of fiber content and
water content tend to be foods with low
energy density so you know fibrous
fruits and vegetables melons like
watermelon has really low energy density
uh most green leafy vegetables stuff
like that what they found uh was if
you're able to incorporate foods with
low energy density and get the energy
density of your meal in in its totality
down to like
1.75 or 2 kilocalories per gram and in
that particular scenario the volume of
food you're eating seems to be the
limiting factor that convinces you okay
meals over you've eaten plenty of just
bulk food content but when you get into
meals that have higher energy density so
we're talking about over like two and a
half three kilogram calories per gram in
that situation it's usually just the
calorie content of the meal that plays
the rate limiting role in determining
when it's time to stop eating so even if
you have this meal that's like five
kilocalories per gram like really high
energy density if you say hey I'm gonna
put in a couple stalks of celery to try
to you know you know cut into that
energy density it's probably not going
to do much because it's going to bring
you down from 5 to 4.8 and and you're
still in that range where where calorie
intake is the dominant signal so
just to give some kind of practical
takeaways from the totality of this
literature
so that people can strategically
uh revisit their food source selection
uh number one regulation of energy
intake is really complex it's really
complicated and it comes down to a lot
more than macronutrient distribution so
it's absolutely true that flexible
dieting is an effective strategy it's
absolutely true that mixing in different
foods that fit your Macros will
absolutely keep you you know on the road
toward whatever goal you're pursuing you
know if you're still hitting your Macros
effectively but what what I'm trying to
indicate in this segment is that we can
make that job a little bit easier by
choosing food sources strategically such
that we are not working so hard to kind
of override these different signals
related to hunger satiety and Hyper
palatability and the way that affects
our reward control center so we can you
know If It Fits your Macros works it's
valid flexible dieting totally valid but
we can strategic quickly swap in
different food sources in a way that
really meaningfully impacts our ad
libidum energy intake or just our desire
to eat more when we're on a diet so
whether you're bulking or you're cutting
or you're maintaining I would encourage
people to consider a few factors when
they're selecting food sources number
one is energy density again high fiber
content high water content low mass uh
or you know looking looking at low
energy per unit of mass or volume in
that meal low energy density tends to be
really helpful if you're struggling with
Hunger if satiety is low and hunger is
high trying to have meals with low
energy density is very helpful and you
could look at two different meals with
the same macros but one has different
energy density that is going to
meaningfully influence your experience
as a Dieter both can get you where
you're going with your body comp goal
but one path can be a lot easier than
the other if you're struggling with
Hunger right and then if you're bulking
it goes the opposite direction
if you're like really struggling to get
enough calories in and you're eating a
bunch of really low energy density meals
you can strategically change that and
and go toward higher energy density
meals and potentially make the process a
little bit easier so I'm not saying that
you know flexible dieting doesn't work
I'm saying that we can still work on
that macro Target framework but make
these meals a little bit more compatible
with the way our body actually regulates
energy intake yeah uh other things you
want to keep in mind and again I want to
reiterate when you're talking about
energy density and really trying to
effectively leverage it some of this new
Research indicates you want to look at
meal level energy density not just
saying oh I'm going to bring some celery
with my cheesecake and that's going to
work out great right you want to try to
get the whole meal into that into that
range of being under like 1.75 or 2
kilocalories per gram other things
texture and level of processing again if
you're struggling dealing with hunger
and you want to boost satiety a little
bit harder texture lower level of
processing generally speaking that's
painting with a broad brush but you know
these are the kind of Trends and
patterns we see
foods that you're likely to consume
slower probably will help you know there
are some foods like for example if
you're eating nuts that you have to
crack each nut individually that's kind
of a unique way to slow down your eating
rate compared to just a big bowl of nuts
that are already pre-shelled or
pre-cracked right so there's some really
fun or interesting research where
they'll take the same damn food and just
find ways to make people eat it slower
and a slower rate of food intake can be
helpful when it comes to promoting
satiety like that uh like the classic
apple apple juice study yeah yeah there
is a study where they they had some
people drink apple juice and like just
out of a glass and other people eat it
like soup with a spoon and yes slowing
things down changing texture there's
also study Apple studies Apple where
related where they take a whole apple or
a mashed up Apple and the whole Apple
tends to be better for satiety than
mashing it up into a softer more
processed form
palatability again you want your meals
to taste good but maybe not absolutely
phenomenal when you're dieting because
that the way it lights up that reward
signal or that Reward Center of your
brain can actually override some of
those satiety signals and lead to some
degree of dysregulation of of the hunger
and satiety circuits and dysregulation
might be a strong word but you can
override satiety signals that would have
otherwise convinced you hey we're good
here we don't need to eat more yeah
that's that's like a distillation of the
common saying like oh there's always
room for dessert yeah you know like you
could be stuffed but it's like ah little
bowl of ice cream Little Slice of
Cheesecake I can find room for that yeah
absolutely
um so yeah texture speed of consumption
palatability food combinations like I
said you might consider saying you know
what whenever I eat this I crave the
other so maybe I'm just gonna not eat
either of them and do a different food
swap that's going to be uh you know it's
gonna help me stay on track and not feel
like I have to work so hard and you so
much willpower to hit these macro
Targets on a daily Target uh and of
course anytime you're talking about food
source cost matters ease of preparation
matters uh cooking and storage you know
the feasibility of making the food and
having it when you need it that stuff
all matters and so like I said the thing
that's going to dictate your progress
toward your body composition goal your
Fitness goal of course a major major
element probably the most important
thing is your macro targets hitting the
right General amount of you know carbs
fats and protein every day and special
specifically your calorie intake and
your protein intake in most cases those
those are the two numbers that are
really going to dictate your body
composition progress again under the
assumption that you're not like
tremendously deficient in micronutrients
right so the whole premise of setting
macro targets and really prioritizing
those and using food swaps that get you
to those macro targets completely valid
and I'm not trying to take away from
that what I'm trying to do is remind
people you have a really valuable tool
in your pocket even when you're doing
flexible dieting or this kind of If It
Fits your Macros approach you can
strategically utilize food swaps and
substitutions and leverage your food
source selection in a way that doesn't
make your diet necessarily more
effective but makes adherence easier and
makes the process subjectively much more
enjoyable and it can take you from a
place where a certain set of macro
targets leaves you hungry every night to
a situation where you actually feel uh
you know like you have a really high
level of satiety your hunger's under
control and you feel like you really
don't have to exert too much willpower
to hit those Targets on a daily basis so
I would encourage people if you're
dieting whether it's you know like I
said weight gain weight loss weight
maintenance
revisit your food source selection with
all of these factors in mind and ask
yourself is there a way that I can
strategically alter my food source
selection not to make my diet more
effective but to make it more feasible
more enjoyable more in line with my
preferences and to help me regulate my
hunger and satiety cues more effectively